your legacy is every life you've touched
and that shifted the way I saw legacy or
what you leave behind or what you do
money is important but it's not number
one there's something above number one
if there isn't you're gonna quit you're
gonna feel deflated you're gonna give up
way too soon every footstep that's
everything why you've been on this earth
it's accounted for and will be counted
one day rise and shine it's in spresso
time what's up believe nation it's evan
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I believe you have Michael Jordan
level talent at something and I want you
to find it embrace it and use it to go
make a positive impact on the world so
grab a cup of coffee and sip on today's
message touch lives every day over to
you Oprah Winfrey remember when I
started the school that I said to my
beloved friend Maya Angelou said Maya
I'm so I'm just so proud that I was able
to create the school I said this is
going to be my greatest legacy and Maya
said to me you have no idea no idea what
your legacy will be she said to me
because your legacy is every life you've
touched and that shifted the way I saw
legacy or what you leave behind or what
you do because Maya was explaining to me
that you know over all the years of
watching your show everybody who decided
that they were going to go back to
school or lose weight or no longer hit
their children or get out of a bad
marriage all of those people who have
seen and experienced your voice and the
same thing with everybody here you have
no idea what your legacy will be your
legacy is every life that you've touched
and we like to think of it I know you
have done amazing things with your
philanthropy we like to think that these
great philanthropic moments are the ones
that leave the impact or will make the
huge difference in the world but it's
really what you do
every day it's how you use your life to
be a light to somebody else's you know
and it's how you use your work as an
expression of your own art whatever that
is this is one of the best messages of
all time for me this is what I wake up
and try to do every single day touch
lives that's my entire purpose what is
believed it's a touch lives I'm sitting
here in California
it's 10:30 p.m. California time for me
that is what's 1:30 11:30 12:30 1:30 I
was up 23 hours in a row the night
before I had four hours sleep last night
and it's 1:30 in the morning from my
time and what am i doing I'm making
videos this was the first time in in
spresso history I'm drinking water
instead of coffee because it's it's late
but what are the other people doing here
I'm at clammer con it's an event for
youtubers I had a full-day meeting
people and they're all off at trampoline
park and you know exploring the city and
having fun and that's great I love it
but I'd rather be here making videos for
you when Nina's not around when Hayden's
not around I went by myself the default
is to work I want to touch lives I'm
away from Toronto I'm away from my wife
to be here I'm away from my son to be
here it has to be meaningful it has to
be impactful I need to touch lives I'm
not here to go have fun on a on a
trampoline park that's not fun for me
this is fun for me this is more fun for
me than hopping around the trampoline
park because touching lives is fun
touching lives is at the core of what I
do it's my reason for being it's why I
make all the content that I make and so
when you find the thing that you love
doing when you feel like the work that
you're doing is important you don't get
as burnt out you don't need the breaks I
work through my lunch every day I don't
have a lunch break I don't need the
reset because I love what I do because
I'm I'm at least attempting to touch
lives my arms getting tired I'm gonna
give you an upwards angle cuz I need to
rest my arm on my leg I'm attempting to
touch lives and so if you felt like the
work you did mattered if you felt like
the work you
when you wake up every day is actually
touching lives the game changes that's
when you get real fulfilment and even if
you're not quite there yet just knowing
that you're on the path just knowing
that that's your intention just knowing
that you're in business to try to touch
lives right church lives just during
your business to try to touch lives
instead of just trying to make money
money is important but it's not number
one there's something above number one
if there isn't you're gonna quit you're
gonna feel deflated you're gonna give up
way too soon I don't know there's
anything more important than waking up
and trying to do something to touch
somebody's life I think if you believe
in yourself and you're doing work every
day that matters and that's having an
impact you've won you'll win you'll win
hard look at all your heroes like
everybody look up to look at what their
number one goal was it was never to make
money money is important he just was
never number one number one was touching
people's lives in some way to the best
of their ability as much as possible
every single day day in day out and so
you need to do for your business too so
question of the day I want to know how
do you touch lives what's your favorite
way what do you do on a regular basis
that you can be world class at that
changes the way people see themselves
that brings in same value how do you
touch lives leaving the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso
[Music]
you
if life was to end right now how would
you be remember like how will somebody
think about you
every footstep that's everything why
you've been on this earth
it's accounted for and will be counted
one day
we all gotta face judgment date one day
so I found out very early in life
ain't no there are no bricks in life my
greatest pain I've ever had in my entire
life I'm 39 years old I'll be 40 in
three weeks and for the first time for
the first time in my life
33 years old 39 33 and the first time I
actually had a chance to meet my father
and it bothered me so much because I
still look at myself in the mirror
sometimes I say I know I'm Who I am
[Music]
now the question remains why inside of
me there was a burn that has never
stopped burning that was a crime that I
made up in my mind the first time I fell
on my knees I never forget it I'm
praying and some fall on my knees and I
was just really cannelli and I fell on
my knees and I and the first time I
heard God's voice he said can you hear
me now but I'm asking to hear daddy's
voice I'm every Christmas I'm sitting at
Christmases with a bag packed I got a
t-shirt in the bag and one pair of jeans
I got a toothbrush for no toothpaste and
I'm saying daddy gotta come today
daddy got to come this Christmas
[Music]
daddy never came so I had a decision to
make at a very early age what I fold and
when I make up my mind to be remember
forever
I made up my mind to be remember forever
I did it
I did it you know what I did I did it my
way
I did it my way
and today
I need a young man to change that
attitude of life and do it their way
there's somebody sitting in this
audience that has one thing to do the
moment you leave here
make up in your mind that I'm a
different person make up in your mind
that there's something way greater than
me everybody in this room
this thing can have a real change in
somebody's life by the way you live your
own life
no pain lasts always no pain so like
maybe you could talk about your like
your name why you stylized it like that
um especially other pretty vocal and who
that's it on March 2 I felt like with
the name Rock Kim is like being named
after like Tupac Shakur or Michael
Jordan you know it was I think no shoes
too big to try to fulfill and I wanted
to kind of pioneer my own legacy you
know I wanted to leave back my own path
I didn't want to be like oh well yeah
everybody know about him cuz he came out
and yeah that famous rappers name and
Nam and I wanted to start respectfully I
wanted to earn my name and I was the
whole point of this last album at long
last ASAP because it's basically in
abbreviations is a lot ala and it's like
the return of the goddamn seat Rock
killing was the god I'm seeing I'm
finally accepting that my name's Rock
Kim and I'm taking ownership of it and I
just want to make Rock Kim my mother my
father people Slick Rick Big Daddy Kane
those kind of people I want to make them
proud the most important if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or that would
be like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details